four and two feels great for the
Panthers yeah it's because they lost two
games four days apart to start the
season they lost to the Rams they lost
to the Buccaneers what the hell's wrong
with Cam Newton oh we know what's wrong
he's got a mid-foot sprain that he had
hidden from the team and the team acted
like they didn't know what was going on
since then Kyle Allen four starts four
wins we saw the great win in you sound
like deaf online diner yes I don't even
know what that reference is I just I'm
used to you saying I don't I don't I
didn't see it or you see that movie is
very funny so anyway uh was it oh yeah
Carolina's pants it's gonna be healthy
right right what do you do and it's
funny because you've already got people
who are like oh well you're not saying
the same thing about Drew Brees
well drew Brees is the all-time passing
yardage leader when he's healthy he's
back playing again Kyle Allen is the
future Cam Newton is the we don't know
what right now for the Carolina Panthers
yes he was the MVP four years ago but
he's either injured or we're worried
about the next injury with Cam Newton it
never stops and this is a way for them
to break that cycle and just go with a
guy who can run the offense who you
don't have this constant fear that we're
doing too much or are we not doing
enough where we holding him back or we
putting them at risk and I think it's a
liberating feeling for the Panthers to
not have that that constant criteria
right of Cam Newton's proper use
hovering over the end or a tiny practice
and be healthy and all those things so
yeah and I don't I mean it's I think
it's a pretty serious injury I really do
right and if you're the Panthers you
kind of want to let this ride III hear
you you know I will stand by what I've
been saying I still think the Carolina
Panthers will be at their best with a
healthy Cam Newton but right now Kyle
Allen's gonna make it hard on them to
make that move right away until like Cam
Newton's a hundred and ten percent and
you know yes I mean he's for no as a
starter now they got a bye week you know
no I don't want to throw Cam Newton out
there in the next game they got a play
at San Francisco 49ers and that group
you know maybe you know maybe that's the
game where okay we put Kyle on there one
more time we see if he is for real and
maybe that's the game
you start to draw the line on you know
oh gosh you know we were kind of
steamrolled by that that 49ers defense
maybe that'll show them yeah I think
that'll be a huge point for them it's
either gonna show them man Kyle Allen's
surreal and we got to ride this out
because we beat the San Francisco 49ers
or even if they lost close I think you
still have to ride with them but if they
like feel like we got overwhelmed and
Kyle Allen was overwhelmed by their team
a little bit maybe that finally does
give them the confidence to go back to
Cam Newton I think as I've said before
that when camp noon is healthy and
you're ready to go back to him when this
Kyle Allen thing cools off if and when
it cools off you can go back to Cam
Newton and you can just do Cam Newton
things I'm not worried about him getting
injured because if he gets injured yeah
you've got another guy right fine there
yeah here's the other thing too here's
the other reason why I think there's a
presumption that we're going to see Drew
Brees and a question about whether we're
going to see Cam Newton we see Drew
Brees every game right we see Drew Brees
doing the thumb flexes getting ready to
go and he's there and he's helping Teddy
Bridgewater yeah Cam Newton's been out
of sight out of mind yeah and and the
team says well you know we don't want
him to be standing on that foot while
they have benches yeah he could be on
the bench he could have the tablet he
could be helping Kyle Allen and he's
just not around and I think that's part
of the out-of-sight out-of-mind
off we go and you know Cam Newton's got
one year left after this season on his
contract and I always thought this was
an upper out year for Cam Newton anyways
yeah tensioner he's gonna be gone right
right now it feels like he's gonna be
gone yeah you have to ask at some level
just he want to be there is he thinking
at this stage of my career maybe my best
play is to go somewhere else I don't
know where he'd want to go right but
maybe my best play is to go somewhere
else yeah you know maybe he certainly
has made his mark on the city he's still
a phenomenal phenomenal football player
and yeah hey there are teams that don't
don't let injured players be around and
do that stuff like New England you're
not gonna see any injured players in the
sidelines during that you know I don't
know what Cam Newton's reason is I don't
know if I necessarily believe what
they're saying either way I think it's
smart by Cam Newton North Carolina who's
not there it can be a distraction with
him there I mean gosh let's just talk
about the guys that are there that are
playing football I think the last three
weeks we would have watched these games
Carolina's playing and there would have
been like 10 minutes to vote a day Cam
Newton sitting on the sidelines you know
and what are they gonna do in Camden and
you know you don't have to hear that or
the Carolina Panthers don't have to deal
with it so I understand them kind of
keeping him out of the spotlight when
this goes on but Kyle Allen again not
doing things where I go oh wow this is
so amazing just really playing the
position pure he's just taken what's
there to be had every now and then he'll
make it throw over you go ooh that was
pretty good throw good for Kyle Allen
and of course they can run the ball and
they got a defense and you know this is
why we thought they would be in the NFC
playoffs right but I mean we knew this
team was good they really blew two early
season games because of Cam Newton in
his health status and you know now
they're gonna be in a fight to make the
playoffs I've got two teams I'm
intrigued by that I'm thinking about I'm
projecting into the future seeing Cam
Newton yeah right yeah I want to hear
the Chargers okay that's a good one
Chargers yeah you trying to get a new
stadium right Cam Newton man you know it
just feels like this Phillip Rivers
thing he's gonna be one of the aging
quarterbacks maybe the only one who
doesn't get to leave on his own terms I
think he's done after this year based on
what we've seen so far this season and
also hey ten Bay Buccaneers put them in
Bruce Arians if they don't keep Jameis
Winston and you don't want me Carolina
I'll show you Carolina I've got the
Brett Favre over that river Gerald McCoy
I'm gonna stay in the division and I'm
gonna stick it to you every chance I
that's interesting thought certainly I
mean that is a very interesting thought
really I haven't thought about this at
all I'm just trying to look at it
there's any other teams that jump out to
me nobody else in the NFC I don't see
but I like where you're at there and
then you know there's gonna be teams
like the Cincinnati Bengals that I think
gonna be going I'm gonna want to play
for them I wouldn't think so
draft somebody you know they just to
force them to come to you yeah right
Tennessee Titans I go where do they got
sexy enough yeah maybe not either I hear
yeah I mean it's not happening Cleveland
Indy Oakland yeah so I mean though I
think you might have hit the team's
really on the head there there where it
could be a possibility
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports